on the way in here I pass Bonnie who's
on the ground King passed out because of
this pie I don't want to try this this
is done so today I'm trying the flaming
Ron which is apparently the world's
hottest meat pie I'm really nervous I'm
gonna die I've seen a few people run out
of the room so I don't like this I
really don't think it's gonna be that
hot I have to sign a health and safety
waiver I've never signed a waiver food
food before I'm aware that these product
contains the hottest known ingredients
on planet earth which could lead to
stress to the heart asthma attacks and
other problems so there are only times
you ever really have to sign a waiver is
when you're about to die and people
don't want to get sued all right
bring it on
holy [ __ ] Oh
oh my god I usually don't tear up and I
feel like I'm about to cry
yeah oh man I can feel that going all
the way down I just need some milk
I hope they said to eat a cucumber damn
it's hot that is the hardest thing I've
ever eaten I definitely understand the
disclaimer now like I feel like my brain
might start dripping out of my ears
right now this does nothing I just
vomited outside but I think that's
because ice cold a liter and a half of
warm skim milk this is how I sleep now
I'm gonna need tissue holy crap so
people can eat a full one how the PU
alive that's the most intense thing I've
ever had in my mouth I feel like I'm
gonna die and if I don't die I want to
die Lord to the makers of this pie hats
off to you you have made something that
has ruined an entire office The Flaming
Runner has bested me I would give you a
funny line to end on but there's nothing
King funny about the Empire I'd like to
go I'm taking this oh my god
you